we're not at war with the high supreme
court you want to bully the coal let me
send you
the two god forbid no when you cooperate
with the state of israel
your your situation economic situation
and peace is far far better
than trying to attack us we will not
give up an inch of security
because unfortunately they flip on us
there's turmoil in israel with mounting
demonstrations against the prime
minister
accused of corruption and mishandling
the spiraling health crisis
my guest this week from jerusalem is
near barkat a former mayor of the city
and a leading politician in mr
netanyahu's liquid party
are the wheels finally coming off the
prime minister's wagon
[Music]
welcome to conflict zone prime minister
netanyahu
is under increasing pressure over
accusations of corruption which he's
denied
and his handling of the pandemic the
approval rating on that
seems to have sunk to just under 30
percent how long before
the party liquid party says enough and
it's time he stood aside at least
temporarily
well first of all shalom from jerusalem
i think the biggest challenge we have
right now
is the coronavirus the economics the
medical challenges
we have a large government of over 70
uh parliament members supporting it in
the coalition
the issue you raise is not in the
critical path of the challenges israel
has right now
there are challenges on economics and
the medical side
and the trial which is happening in
parallel
is not an issue for us israelis here mr
barquette
he's on trial on three serious counts of
corruption and come
january the court expects him to be
there three days a week
you really want a prime minister who's
half in and
half out of the dock at the same time
prime minister netanyahu is doing a very
good job in managing israel
um and so i think he's got very strong
support
by the public he has a wide coalition
and everyone understands that we prefer
the best prime minister and he will
manage the trial he will manage
he will no no doubt in my mind he'll be
able to manage the country
he's doing many many things
simultaneously now he will continue
doing that with the trial
remind you that he's innocent until
proven guilty
and everyone we want everyone that goes
to court
to prove his innocence he calls the
whole thing
a witch hunt but what if he's convicted
in the end you and the party would go
down with him
are you prepared for that the liquid
party is the leading party in the
country
we have the right ideology the
experience we have a wide
array of talented and good people
the liquid party will continue even
after netanyahu finishes his role
i personally intend to run for office
and
replace netanyahu once he decides to
step down
so like has a long history and a big
future ahead of us
yeah do you buy into the kind of
conspiracy that he says
has been waged against him elements in
the police and the prosecution joined
forces with the leftist media
to manufacture baseless and absurd cases
against me he said
a conflict of interest that cries out to
the heavens
leaving aside the rhetoric the
melodramatic
rhetoric do you really expect people to
believe that state prosecutors colluded
to do all that
the state attorney several judges state
witnesses
all part of this grand conspiracy you
buy into that
well let's put it this way um netanyahu
believes in his innocence and he feels
that
he is getting an unfair treatment both
by the press
and and many many other elements maybe
also in the police and then
and other elements of the um the legal
system in our country
that's what he feels and he's saying
that um you know
if it's such a rotten justice system mr
mr buck if it's such a rotten justice
system as he paints it
why did he not find out over the last 10
years and do something about it
turns out it's only a rotten system when
it goes after him isn't that
the truth there are all systems in our
country and i believe
also in yours needs
to upgrade and change in time
at any given moment in time we have to
upgrade the legal system
the court system the naturally the
government um
the parliament which i'm part of we must
nobody has immunity from change and and
and evolutions and i think that part of
the issues
definitely we have to restructure some
of the elements in the in the
relationship between the parliament and
the government
and the legal system this is the first
time mr barcat a
serving israeli prime minister has been
formally charged with criminal offences
why not do the honorable thing and stand
aside in order to fight the indictment
and clear his name
or does this liquid-led government not
worry about senior figures under
investigation
it certainly doesn't worry about past
convictions of some of its members does
it
tim we have a law in our country and the
law is
specifically and explicitly says that
the prime minister
can continue serving in his role until
the high supreme court decides otherwise
and and the reason this
law exists is that if somebody wants to
kick out a prime minister
he could charge him and then what
happens once the prime minister's
found that he's not guilty
then you've overthrown the prime
minister just by putting charges against
him it doesn't make any sense
that's why the israeli law says that he
can continue
serving his role until until proven
guilty
by the high supreme court and so we're
just following the law
and it makes a lot of sense you have to
understand it makes sense that's the
letter of the law mr barca but there's
also morality something which
has brought mr netanyahu scathing
criticism from judges on the israeli
supreme court
menachem mazu said a situation in which
a defendant charged with serious ethical
crimes
forms a government and heads it raises a
public
and moral problem whose magnitude is
hard to overstate
justice uzi fogelman said that for the
knesset to choose a prime minister
charged with bribery
undermines the public's faith in its
servants
you have no qualms about it you're not
interested in the morality that the
supreme court is talking about here
the answer is we had elections and all
of what you've said
was put right on the table to the
israeli public and israeli public
decided
to vote for prime minister netanyahu and
the government the 70
plus parliament members that are part of
the coalition out of 120 parliament
members
are the answer the public understands
exactly what you're saying
what the the uh what some of the judges
said
and went to the ballots and voted
netanyahu
so the answer is we understand all that
we understand that there's a law we
understand that other people think
otherwise
but the public decided to support
netanyahu
in spite of these challenges therefore i
feel comfortable
that we are first of all working by the
law
enabling the public to choose their
prime minister
the prime minister now was able to
create a large wide coalition
and that is the answer to the courts the
israelis that understand and and
we we were democracy the only democracy
in the middle east
nobody around us yeah well he has such a
strong democracy you say that you say
that but one of the judges justice anna
baron said that appointing
prime minister who's indicted on serious
charges doesn't
accord with the fundamental principles
of israeli democracy but you're not much
interested in what the judges on the
supreme court think
are you that's not true the that well
fact factually you're wrong because i'll
give you an example
let me give you an example what is what
has particularly annoyed your party
especially about the supreme court is
the fact that it struck down the law you
passed in 2017
which retroactively legalized illegal
settlements
and that was something your party hasn't
been able to forgive wasn't it we had
howls of hysterical protest in june
settlements minister tzipi hotavali
accusing the court of declaring war on
the right of jews to settle in the land
of israel
really declaring war on the right of
jews is that what you think the
the supreme court has been up to
we're not at war with the high supreme
court everyone respects him they have
maybe sometimes a um i would say
an extreme opinion on matters specific
matters but we all
accept the high supreme court judgments
we believe
that the relationship between the
parliament
and the high supreme court there are
other places in the world that have
different relationships for example in
israel the high supreme court
um for a few times ruled that laws that
we are
we've created in the parliament are
illegal and
there are other democracies in the world
that don't enable the high supreme court
to rule out laws that are defined by the
parliament
when you are certain that this minister
didn't exist this is not the case
your settlements minister didn't accept
the judgment from the supreme court
do you accept what the court told you
with that law that it legalized
illegal building by jews in the west
bank and had deeply harmful consequences
for the substantive rights of
palestinians question is then why are
you passing laws that are so harmful
for the palestinians for the subs their
substantive rights
why do you pass laws like that in the
first place first of all
i respect the high supreme court i will
always respect them
even if i don't agree with them uh on
the other hand
we are now in the parliament i'm a
parliament member from the liquid party
i want to change the laws
so that we have better quality of life
you want to change
this laws or believe that you know i was
mayor of jerusalem you want to bully the
court
don't you the two there are two
god forbid no you said that the time has
come to restore the
last of power between the branches of
government what's that mean
another attempt to bully the court god
forbid no
the answer is that we look at other
democracies in the world and we see that
the relationships are different
than the balance is different in the
united states
the uh the president of the united
states he chooses the
the high supreme court judges in other
places
there's no there's different balances
and we learn from other democracies
so let me just focus on the point you
said
in judea and samaria anywhere you put a
shovel in the ground you find jewish
roots
and jews are allowed to live anywhere
they want in the world in new york
in germany in london in jerusalem
anywhere in arab countries they can live
anywhere they want especially
in places that anywhere you put a shovel
you find our roots and our history in
the bible
and that's not it's in the bible okay
now
from my perspective jews could live
there and right now applying israeli
sovereignty israeli laws
on israeli cities and towns in judea and
scenario
is the right thing to do from my
political perspective
i want to come on
that i want to come on to the issue of
annexation a bit later
i want to talk first about the issue of
hate speech which has been coming from
your party
this year's state department report on
human rights from your friendly trump
administration
accuses your party directly of promoting
hatred
it said during the april and september
national elections last year the liquid
party
deployed messages promoting hatred
against arab citizens
including a chatbot message on the prime
minister's facebook
page saying the arabs want to destroy
all of us
women children and men facebook had to
suspend it and the prime minister said
he wasn't aware of the message
was liquid really so desperate in those
elections
that it had to resort to such cheap
tactics
tim i was a mayor of jerusalem for a
decade 10 years
and every time i heard somebody to speak
hatred to any side i was always against
it
the likud party as a whole believes in
living together in cooperation we have
within the liquid party
muslims christians and jews and jews and
others we have
um all kinds of you know
haredi which is ultra orthodox and
secular
we have it all we are a party that
focuses on how to live together
sometimes people may step offline in
terms of their speech
i will always be there to remind them
that hatred is not the way
that we that's not part of our dna
mister did you did you remind them
during the
course of that did you remind them in
the course of the elections which
brought a torrent of false charges
against arabs
the prime minister himself said that if
it hadn't been for voting fraud in the
april election
the arab party ballot would not have
passed the electoral threshold
same from the tourism minister yariv
levin the suspicions are that there are
over a hundred polling stations that are
heavily is suspected of irregularities
what was the reality nothing of the kind
the director general of the central
elections committee
said a police investigation after the
april election found suspicion of fraud
in two polling stations in the arab
sector not a hundred
just two and this fraud he said had
ended up benefiting
liquid as well as shas another
right-wing party
so these allegations that came forth
during the elections
i don't remember you challenging any of
them but they were
it was a breathtaking level of
dishonesty from your party wasn't it
tim people get carried away in elections
all sides
not just the liquid practically all
parties unfortunately sometimes get
carried away in their election
in the elections unfortunately this is
not just an israeli issue
i think it's the same in the united
states and in europe in many many places
um i am a person that seeks to
focus on the common denominator of
people to unite people and i will always
be against
such statements yeah but it's not
happening
no wonder your president reuven rivlin
commented in january this year
when the nation witnesses its leaders
spewing hatred at one another
boycotting entire communities and
seeking votes via a strategy of
divisiveness
what's left for them to believe in
there's nothing in that statement of his
for your party to feel proud about is
there
tim i said earlier people get carried
away in the elections
i personally and i know that this is
part of the dna of the likud
is seek the common denominator and if
people step
out of line in what they're saying i
will always be there and i
always was there to say that it must we
must focus on
on different ways to speak and this is
not just for likud
i'm saying this is a liquid parliament
member it's true for
all our parliament unfortunately in
elections people get heated up
and uh sometimes misspeak it's not just
it's not just about the election
not just the podcast it's not just about
elections nowhere
is the hardship that the palestinians
live under more apparent
than in the city that you ran for two
terms as mayor jerusalem
again your american friends in the trump
administration are scathing
about the lack of services for non-jews
in jerusalem their latest report says
arab christians and muslims jews and
ethiopian citizens
face persistent institutional and
societal
discrimination this is disgraceful
enough isn't it but if you go back
and look at previous reports this
discrimination has been flagged up year
after year
and nothing was done to improve the
situation why
well i think you're describing the
situation in the united states of
america and many other european
countries
um i can tell you this round i've done
fine you're i'm just saying that uh um
if you look at the facts the quality of
life
of arab residents in east jerusalem is
far far better
than any of the arabs countries around
us and the reason
that's not much of a comparison of
jerusalem
oh of course it is the alternative they
have is far worse
and so all the non-democ democracies
around us
none of them are democracies their
quality of life
is far far worse if you look at the um
the
how many the wages of people the arab
israelis
their wages is much much higher than in
in
judea and samaria the the wages of arab
israelis in jerusalem
the uh the arab residents is far far
greater
than in jordan and any other world in in
egypt in syria or any other place
and so mr bakken mr barca minute to do
that mr barca the proof of neglect and
double standards lies it lies in the
statistics doesn't it
figures quoted by the state department
from the jerusalem institute for policy
research
for 2017 show the dire conditions in
which palestinians live in jerusalem
78 of arab residents there and
86 of arab children in east jerusalem
lived that year in poverty and that's a
policy decision isn't it are you proud
of that
god forbid that's not a policy and by
the way you forgot to mention that we
have
a huge a large ultra-orthodox community
in jerusalem
that that is is very similar to the arab
communities
the arab communities around the country
are
if you look at the all villages in our
country you find that their
social economic status is lower
unfortunately now what i've done
is i've focused on education improve the
quality of education
there unfortunately some of the arab
residents choose the palestinian system
the education system which is
far more far less better than the
israeli system
we've done everything to improve both
quality of life
infrastructure tourism went up before
coronavirus to
high high numbers and and it's a big
huge employer of arab residents
and the arab residents are much much
better
as part of the jerusalem the united city
of jerusalem
than any other solution and the fact is
the reality is that they
understand that it's much much better
working and cooperating
with the state of israel than anything
else
that when you cooperate with the state
of israel your
your situation economic situation and
peace is far far better
than trying to attack us mr barca let's
talk about the prime minister's promise
last september to annex
nearly a third of the occupied west bank
if he was returned to office
a big announcement a july 1st timetable
and the assurance in may to a liquid
faction meeting
we don't intend to change the deadline
well the deadline has come and gone
did you underestimate the international
condemnation
of such a move well first of all
in any future deal with the palestinians
they're no nobody goes out from their
home
all israeli towns and cities stay where
they are
therefore in any scenario in any
situation applying israeli law
on israeli citizens living in judea
samara is the right thing to do
so we start for this is the right thing
to do it's a bit more than the second
point
isn't it it's a bit more than that
because if annexation goes ahead
it's the end of any hope of a
functioning state for the palestinians
isn't it the prime minister said in may
palestinians literally the jordan valley
would not be given israeli passports
after annexation but would be citizens
of a future palestinian entity and
subject to israeli security
control you will continue to dictate the
security
conditions to palestinians that's what
this is going to be about
isn't it tim listen there are three
pillars of cooperating with the
palestinians in judea and samaria the
first
is civil separation they manage their
own cities and towns
we manage the israeli cities and towns
second point a hundred percent full
israeli security
we will not give up an inch of security
because unfortunately they flip on us
the third element
is a joint economy that we must develop
because when we work together
in uh palestinians and israelis work
together
in our industrial zones and in tourism
it is far far better for the
palestinians and the israelis and so the
joint
economy is something we must develop
these are the three pillars of living
together between israelis and
palestinians in judea and samaria
they we don't want to manage and we do
not manage nablus
ramallah and other arab cities and towns
and similarly they will not manage ours
nobody is going anywhere
we must learn to live together in peace
and harmony and
when there is peace in any scenario
israeli law will apply in israeli
cities and towns mr brown the rest of
the world isn't
buying your comforting assurances the
u.n high commissioner for human rights
michelle bachelet
summed up the prevailing view annexation
is illegal
period she said any annexation
any annexation well i totally disagree i
totally disagree and the americans now
understand that the land in judea and
samaria
is oh is is the land of the jews and we
have no problem live with the
palestinians side by side
and enable them to have their own civil
they have their civil
uh uh autonomy we don't want to get
involved in their civil autonomy
do the americans really understand that
do the americans really understand that
sippy hotel valley your settlements
minister said last month there are gaps
between the americans and
us on this issue there are gaps what
gaps
fine what gaps the gap is not around
understanding that the
israeli cities and towns are legal
americans understand that
um there are some gaps in uh with some
of the americans naturally
we don't disagree but they're not from
my perspective
they're not a game changer in terms of
what has to be done
the challenges are how large with the
um applying israeli law
what is the map how is it going to look
like and on these details
there are challenges and we're working
together with our american friends
to define that we do not want to
uh rule the palestinian civil life
we propose better cooperation on the
joint economy and we will not give up
the right
to defend ourselves and make sure that
we have full
israeli security control on every inch
of judea and same area
and this is a joke you want real peace
if joseph's the only way to get real
peace if joe biden becomes
president in november wins the election
in november becomes president next year
you will have missed what the prime
minister called a historic opportunity
he's dead set against this annexation
isn't he
well first of all let's see that he wins
the elections and we will
any american president that will win we
will sit with him and share our views
and do everything we can in the liquid
party to do the right thing
to uh to to take to apply israeli law
on israeli cities and towns will be the
right thing to do in
any potential deal in the future you
have one country as one of your
commentators put it in the newspaper
you have one country with two peoples
four regimes
democracy for jews discrimination for
israeli arabs
military dictatorship for palestinians
in the west bank
and prison for their brothers in the
gaza strip you're really telling me
you're proud of that
that's total nonsense with your
permission the reality
is that we will give a hand and create
peace with
our enemies we've done that with egypt
40 years we have peace with egypt
they're
by far the biggest enemy of israel
similarly with jordan
and israel knows how to create
real peace deals unfortunately look what
happens in the hamas in gaza
we left gaza one-sidedly
the israeli army left gaza and what did
we get everyone talked about
the future of gaza as being uh
you know hopefully a beautiful place for
uh business what did they do
you you're relaxing you left gaza but
you stood outside and you're controlling
everything that goes in and
everybody who goes in and out with all
due respect i heard that gaza
i heard that gaza will be the singapore
of the middle east now the
israeli army is not there what happened
is exactly the opposite
so people that are saying uh god forbid
if you leave uh security um in
in judea and samaria we will get the
gaza uh the hamas
right next to jerusalem and all the the
the heart of israel
all right we'll never make that mistake
again mr
we could go on discussing this much
longer unfortunately we've run out of
time thank you very much for being on
conflict zone appreciate your time my
pleasure thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you